Suzuki's sx/4 s-cross is the latest
addition to the car makers selection of
models the new version is distinctly
larger and more comfortable than the
previous SX 4 which will still be
available in a classic version we're
testing an 88 kilowatt diesel the broad
range of features stand out during mock
solid ski from Suzuki touts the large
430 litre trunk and a full range of what
are usually extras even in the basic
version for example cruise control a
speed limiter a standard start/stop
system and air conditioning and more is
available for a bit more money our test
car has a navigation system to zone
automatic air conditioning heated
leather seats front and back and
electric windows all around and there's
an extra in the top-of-the-line model
available in Germany that our test
driver Montes kirat is crazy about he
loves the huge panoramic glass sunroof
it opens very wide providing a feeling
almost like a convertible but then you
have to live with the sound of the wind
the SX 4s cross is available with front
or intelligent all-wheel drive with
special programs for snow and sand but
its most at home on the road it needs 12
seconds to sprint up to 100 kilometers
an hour fuel consumption in the
two-wheel drive diesel model averages
four point two liters per 100 kilometers
the cars dynamics are satisfying
the clan asked our test driver says he
can't complain about the power provided
by the little 1.6 liter diesel engine in
the sx4 he is driving a gasoline engine
is also available also with 88 kilowatts
of power and fuel consumption of 5.4
liters per 100 kilometers the exterior
has an off-road look with matte silver
trim on the front as well as on the rear
and the door sills the car clears the
ground by about 17 centimeters
the standard trunk holds 430 liters of
luggage that's nothing to sneeze at
it's enough for a country outing with
the family but on winding country roads
the springy suspension makes itself felt
mata says he personally would prefer
tighter steering but reflects that the
buyer of an S x 4's cross is probably
not planning to race with it anyway
mutt has found no real weaknesses in the
SX 4s cross everything is solidly
crafted nothing creaks a rabble's the
starting price for the compact crossover
in Germany is nineteen thousand four
hundred 90 euros depending on the extras
and drivetrain this can rise to as much
as thirty thousand euros
what the protesters says the almost
20,000 euro starting price may seem a
bit high to some potential buyers
especially because there is competition
in this segment but he says that if you
consider the equipment and furnishings
here it's still a good offer done is the
stuff we done Goethe Sangha board
you